[Music]
hi everyone i'm jeff naheke
and i'm dr felia
and we're both customer engineers at
google cloud and we're so glad to have
you back to another episode of technical
guide for startups where we are creating
a series of videos for technical
enablement to start build and grow your
businesses successfully and sustainably
on google cloud
in our previous video we talked about
compute engine and how to configure it
appropriately
now we're on the sixth episode
networking configurations let's dive in
in this video we're going to understand
google's global network do an overview
of vpc networking firewall rules and
load balancing and understand these
concepts better with a few quick
demonstrations based on the instances
we've deployed in our previous compute
with google compute engine video if you
haven't watched that please do check it
out we've linked it in the description
box below
we will then go over a customer success
story and wrap up with some actionable
next steps
so without any further ado let's get
right on to the video for the past 15
years google has been building out one
of the fastest one of the most powerful
and one of the most highest quality
cloud infrastructures on the planet
google runs its own data center to data
center high throughput fiberback and
traffic travels as far as possible on
google's own network
and the result is a global network
connecting our data centers to each
other and to all the major cities across
the globe
think about it this network is so
reliable that many people checking to
see if they can get to google.com is how
they test their home network
most cloud providers use what's called
hot potato routing this is when you're
sending out traffic from their
infrastructure they offload it to the
public internet as soon as possible this
is like a hot potato that they want to
get off their hands
google cloud as well provides this
option in the standard networking tier
but we also do things differently
in google cloud's premium networking tr
we use something called the code potato
routing technique where we keep that
traffic on google cloud's private
network for as long as possible and exit
it to the public internet at the
location closest to the end user usually
in the same town or city
this enables us to offer you with better
reliability better performance and more
security
and this is possible due to the google's
global network we've been talking about
the big benefits being high performance
reduced latency and superior network
quality leading to a delightful user
experience
hence the premium tier is the
recommended and defaultio as it delivers
your traffic over google's global
backbone network
this global network also paves way to
some unique features like global load
balancing cdn and more we'll cover some
of these as we go
coming up next
vpc networking
a vpc or virtual private cloud is your
virtual global network and google cloud
as you can see from this image they are
created within projects
and are made up of subnets
which are regional
vpcs enable private communication
between google cloud regions natively
allowing you to keep a fault tolerant
and highly available network by default
when creating a vpc in the google cloud
console or through the cloud sdk you can
choose from two custom subnet creation
modes auto subnet mode which creates a
subnet for each of google cloud's
existing regions or custom subnet mode
which allows you to create a subnet for
each of the regions you'd like creating
a vpc with custom subnet mode is our
recommended best practice
let's take a look at how to create a vpc
log on to the google cloud console
select the list view of google products
and open vpc network
notice that there is already a network
created called default
which spans all regions
in is of type auto subnet mode
let's now create a new network using
custom subnet mode
select create vpc network
give it an identifiable name
making sure to select custom under
subnet creation mode
in the new subnet box you'll be able to
create multiple subnets
first choose a name
select a region from the drop down and
choose a private ip range for this
subnet
turn private google access on if you
wish to allow vms in this subnet to
communicate with google apis without
needing external ips
then toggle flow logs on if you'd like
to see detailed logs for your network
traffic
notice that toggling this on will incur
extra costs
repeat these steps for all the subnets
you wish to create in this vpc
finally choose global if you need to
make your newly created subnets
available to your on-prem network
if not leave regional selected
click create
your vpc will be provisioned within
seconds
let's talk a bit about firewall rules
unlike a traditional firewall which is a
physical appliance filtering traffic
between subnets
google cloud's firewall rules provide
distributed enforcement at the virtual
networking level
this means that there is no performance
bottleneck or single pointer failure in
using our firewall
firewall rules are included at no extra
cost
and there are no appliances or operating
systems to manage
essentially
every vpc network functions as a
distributed firewall
finally you can think of gcp firewall
rules as existing not only between your
instances and other networks but also
between individual instances within the
same network
when creating a final rule you must
specify a few configurations
at a basic level a final rule needs a
target which controls the instances to
which the rules apply
this can be done by specifying an
instance tag
a service account that's attached to
your instance or simply choosing to
apply the rule to all the instances
next you must choose the direction of
traffic the rules apply to
ingress or egress traffic
the rule can then block or allow the
predetermined flow of traffic
finally you must specify either a source
or a destination for the rule to apply
to depending on which direction of
traffic you chose
let's now take a look at the creation of
a firewall rule
let's create a rule that blocks all
incoming traffic from the internet
still in the google cloud console hover
over the vpc network and select firewall
after selecting create firewall rule
choose a name
select which network this rule applies
to and set a priority
here a lower number means higher
priority
where the highest priority is denoted by
zero
because we're trying to block all
incoming traffic from the internet i'll
select ingress for destination of
traffic and deny for action on match
i'll make this rule apply to all
instances in the network
and in the source ipv4 ranges output
0.0.0
0 to represent any and all traffic
including that from the public internet
the firewall rule is ready so now select
create
another option for the configuration of
a firewall rule is to edit a vm instance
directly on the google cloud console to
allow http traffic
on the instances page click edit
check allow http traffic
then hit save
once the firewall rule is configured
you'll be able to see it in the firewall
rules page where its target is denoted
as http dash server
on the instance page you can see network
tag for this name
http dash server
signifying the relationship between the
rule in the instance
in google cloud we offer different
flavors of load balancers
on the global side depending on the
traffic we have load balancers for http
https ssl and tcp
on the regional side we have network
load balancer and https load balancer
both external and internal facing
external load balancer distribute the
traffic coming from the internet to your
google cloud vpc network on the other
hand internal load balancers distribute
traffic to instances inside your google
cloud
if your back-ends are distributed across
multiple regions go for the global cloud
load balancing if not you can choose
from the regional cloud load balancing
services
google cloud load balancing is built on
the same front-end serving
infrastructure that powers google it
supports 1 million plus queries per
second with high performance and low
latencies
the first picture shows a load balancing
in a traditional cloud provider where
both the load balancer and the instances
sit in the data center the user request
traverses the internet and finally makes
its way to the load balancer that's
sitting in the data center by a cloud
provider as you can see the cloud
provider has no control over the user
experience over the internet so there is
no way to deliver low latency or great
user experience
however it's different with google's
global load balancing since the load
balancing is at 80 plus points of
presence around the world the user
request only traverses the internet for
a short period of time until it reaches
the closest google's point of presence
or pop beyond that the load balancing
system at pops dominate the tcp
connection and delivers the request to
the service over google's high quality
global network the benefits are
significant to name a few it provides
reduced latency and improved throughput
for your users
it also helps in serving static cachable
content from multiple points near your
users
now let's go over a demonstration of how
to enable external https load balancer
for your application we're going to take
into consideration the application we
deployed in our previous video go to the
google cloud console and your home page
opens up select network services and
load balancing or simply type load
balancing in your search and select this
you can see your existing load balancers
here and you're your back-end and
front-end options here
as we had deployed a back-end in our
previous video we see that option listed
here
now let's go ahead and create a load
balancer by clicking on create load
balancer you can choose your load
balancers to be http https load balancer
a tcp load balancer or a udp load
balancer we've already gone over this i
know that you'll be choosing whether you
want them to be internal or external
once you start configuring them right
now i want to configure an external http
https load balancer so let me do that by
clicking on start configuration for this
so here i choose whether it's from the
internet as an external facing or
between my vms as an internal facing
like i said i want this to be external
facing so i'm going to choose from
internet
now give it a name and choose a back-end
service you can either create a backend
service directly here or choose
something that was previously created
like i'm going to choose the one which i
created in the previous video
as you can see another tab got updated
automatically let's quickly review this
the host and path rules here which
essentially tells you that you can load
balance to back in services or cloud
storage bucket which is the object
storage option on google cloud and
because i picked a backend service this
was updated for your front-end
configuration assign a name
select whether you want an http or https
protocol let's just say http
and choose your network tier like from
what we discussed earlier you can choose
whether you want it to be an ephemeral
ip
select the one that was created in the
front end in the previous video or
choose to create a new one as well
give it a name
and select that
select your ip version and port number
let me leave it as is if nothing is
chosen in this section the defaults are
taken
now in this section i get to review my
configurations
and now click on create
now if we refresh it you can see that
your load balancer is here
now that we've created a load balancer
let's quickly test it out
click on this to get to the load
balancer details
then go to monitoring to see the load
balancing
we see this now let me go back to the
details pick up the front and external
ip address and go to a new tab or window
i've just opened up an incognito window
here let me put in the ip address
and as you can see you can see the
guestbook application that we had
deployed
now let me randomly put in some load
now let's go back and check our
monitoring here
you see that there's load coming in from
different continents across the globe to
the front end and hitting it and moving
to the assigned back end now let me go
back and add some intense amount of loot
again
let's quickly refresh this
and here you go you can see that there's
so much more load coming in from asia as
opposed to america and similarly you can
also load balance it further amongst
different back-ends internally and
monitor them
so we successfully created and tested
our external load balancer bringing us
to the end of this demo
google cloud's network is impressive so
let's see what one of our customers
built on top of it
packet fabric is a private network that
provides secure reliable on-demand
services between customers and their
cloud service providers
whether private or public
they help their customers automate their
network connectivity in order to move
their data from one place
to another
packet fabric leverages google's network
to offer a globally interconnected
network as a service platform to its
customers
additionally google cloud's highly
performant vpc networking helps packet
fabrics customers to build provision and
change their network infrastructure
quickly and painlessly
in summary you're a few clicks away from
leveraging google cloud's powerful and
secure network to run your most exciting
and demanding applications
thank you for joining us on this episode
about networking configurations
to continue exploring the vastness of
google cloud networking check out our
suggestions here
and don't hold back on clicking on the
links in the description
that brings us to the end of this video
but don't worry we have some exciting
content for you in our upcoming video in
our next video we're going to look at
the big picture of databases for google
cloud
deep dive into cloud sql and do some
demonstrations for cloud sql along with
some integrations and learn how to
optimize it
we'll also be discussing a sample gaming
application architecture and go over a
success story of a startup customer
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe to our youtube channel hit on
the bell icon to get notified every time
we post a new video
bye now
see you next time
[Music]